das kleine kaukasusland Georgien
rangiert in den letzten Tagen wieder
weit oben in den Nachrichten
tagelang demonstrierten wütend tausende
Menschen vor dem Parlament in Tiflis es
gab heftige Zusammenstöße mit der
Polizei viele Festnahmen und verletzte
so mancher fühlte sich an den Euro
maydan 2014 in der Ukraine erinnert auch
dort gingen die Menschen damals auf die
Straße und forderten den Rücktritt einer
putinfreundlichen Regierung
es besteht kein Zweifel dass die
Proteste gegen das Gesetz über die
Registrierung von
Nichtregierungsorganisationen nur ein
Vorwand waren um einen Versuch zu
starten die Regierung mit Gewalt zu
ändern die Proteste werden natürlich vom
Ausland aus orchestriert mit dem Ziel
Instabilität an den Grenzen Russland zu
schaffen es ähnelt sehr dem Kiefer mydan
sergeantworte auf russische
Außenminister die georgische Volkszähler
kocht nun weil das Parlament ein Gesetz
verabschieden wollte dass viele Menschen
in der ehemaligen Republik als
undemokratisch und einen ersten Schritt
zu einer neuen Russifizierung des Landes
empfanden nach russischen Vorbild wollte
die Regierung kritische Journalisten
Aktivisten und NGOs als ausländische
Agenten brandmarken aber auch nachdem
dieser Gesetzentwurf zurückgezogen wurde
gingen die Proteste weiter die Menschen
in tiefes forderten den kompletten
Rücktritt der Regierung genau die 2014
in Kiel denn sie wissen trotz des
rückziehers hat sich erst einmal nichts
an den politischen Konstellationen in
und umgeorgien geändert
wir werden niemals etwas was aus
Russland akzeptieren und wir wollen
nicht zurück in die UdSSR so einfach ist
das die jüngere Generation die im
unabhängigen Georgien aufgewachsen ist
hat es geschafft sich gehört zu
verschaffen wir hoffen dass die EU uns
dabei unterstützen wird das spannende
dabei die Mehrheitspartei georgischer
Traum steht schon lange im Verdacht eine
betont russlandfreundliche Politik zu
betreiben und das all den katastrophalen
Erfahrungen sind trotz die ein anderer
russischer Nachbar nämlich die Ukraine
seit dem 24 Februar 2022 machen musste
die Regierung in Tiflis hat es abgelehnt
sich den westlichen Sanktion gegen
Moskau anzuschließen und beschuldigte
nun sogar die Ukraine für die Proteste
in tiefes verantwortlich zu sein ich
meine es geht wohl kaum putineska 13
März 2023 georgischer Premierminister
forderte den ukrainischen
Ministerpräsidenten selinski auf sich
nicht in seinem Land einzumischen der
georgische Premierminister irakische
Willi beschuldigte den ukrainischen
Präsidenten bolognesellen die sich in
die politische Situation seines Landes
einzumischen wenn eine Person die sich
im Krieg befindet auf die zerstörerische
Aktion von mehreren tausend Menschen
hier in Georgien reagiert ist das ein
direkter Beweis dafür dass diese Person
involviert und motiviert ist auch hier
etwas zu verändern tja besser hätte es
selbst Putins Sprecher pestov nicht
formulieren können fürchtet die
Regierung in Tiflis etwa von ihrem
großen Nachbarn auch bald denazifiziert
zu werden fakt ist diese Unterwürfigkeit
gegenüber Moskau kommt nicht bei allen
Bürgern gut an und das umstrittene
Gesetze war für viele wohl nur der
sprichwörtliche Tropfen der das fast zum
überlaufen brachte denn georgien hat in
der Vergangenheit tatsächlich schon
Ähnliches erlebt wie ist der Ukraine
heute wieder fährt
lange bevor Putin 2014 die Creme
annektierte und sich kurz darauf den
Donbass unter den nagelriss wurden die
Georgier bereits von russischen Panzern
überrollt das war im Jahr 2008 seither
kontrolliert Russland zwei Provinzen des
Landes ab Asien und südostizien beide
stehen schon seit den 1990er Jahren
unter der Herrschaft von Separatisten
doch 2008 haben sie sich mit
moskausrückendeckung zu unabhängigen
Staaten erklärt zugegeben außer russland
hat sie so gut wie niemand auf der Welt
anerkannt und was heute wo Leute mir
selenski ist nämlich der
unbestrittenes war damals vor 15 Jahren
der georgische Präsident Michael Willi
wir reden hier von echtem Hass weit
jenseits jeglicher diplomatischer
Floskeln beispiel gefällig Wladimir
Putin drohte den georgischen Staatschef
an den Eiern aufzuhängen Saka willi ist
heute wohl schon nicht mehr allen von
euch ein Begriff dabei kann man ihn
durchaus zu Figuren der internationalen
Politik der letzten zwei Jahrzehnte
zählen er ist sozusagen der Klaus Kinski
der Politik genial und
Ära zugleich käme Saka Spiele aus dem
us-bundestag Georgia und nicht aus der
gleichnamigen extra wettrepublik gebe es
wohl schon vier Serien auf Netflix über
ihnen nun ja zumindest haben wir letztes
Jahr bereits ein Video über Georgien
gedreht dass ich euch natürlich
verlinken werde mich als Willi war von
2004 bis 2013 Präsident des kleinen
Landes und da seine Herrschaft ging es
mit der georgischen Wirtschaft deutlich
bergauf und das Land näherte sich den
besten mehr an als je zuvor doch nach
dem sackerspiel ist Partei die Wahl
verloren hatte und auch seine Amtszeit
vorbei war Sankt seinen Stern er ging
ins Exil in die USA während zu Hause
bereits die Staatsanwaltschaft wegen
Amtsmissbrauch gegen ihn ermittelt hatte
okay soweit nichts Ungewöhnliches
derartige Fluchten kommen auch in
anderen Ländern vor doch Saka
schwieriger als bald seine georgische
Staatsbürgerschaft auf und er wurde
Ukraine
denn in jungen Jahren hatte er mal in
Kiew studiert und nun wurde er zunächst
präsidentenberater dann Gouverneur des
Gebiets Odessa dort trat er mit dem
Versprechen an die wuchernde Korruption
bei Zoll und Behörden auszumerzen doch
das alles klappte nicht so recht
zackerspiel überwarf sich mit dem
damaligen Präsidenten broschenko er ging
erneut ins Exil verlor die
Staatsbürgerschaft kehrte zurück wurde
verhaftet wieder abgeschoben liebe Leute
das ist kein Lebenslauf sondern wirkt
wie ein Drehbuch das wo die Ellen könnte
Tarantino und Rainer Werner Fassbinder
zusammen in einer total verkost
durchgesoffenen macht auf einer Rolle
Klopapier hätten zusammen spielen können
und es wäre nie verfilmt worden denn nur
ein einziger Schauspieler kann diese
Rolle überzeugen spielen Klaus fangen
Kinski sagt
aber ich leck mich
man macht doch dein Schatz es
wahnsinniger Idiot
und als ob das noch nicht genug gewesen
wäre wollte ihnen also sakrash Willi
nicht Kinski 2019 der neu gewählte
ukrainische Präsident selenski auch noch
zu vizeprämie und Chef seines nationalen
Rates für Reformen machen aber auch
daraus wurde dann irgendwie doch nichts
deshalb beschloss Saga Spiele 2021 in
seiner Heimat Georgien zurückzukehren
aber glaubt jetzt nicht dass er banal
mit dem Flugzeug eingeflogen wäre wie
normale Menschen er überquerte die
Grenze illegal als blinder Passagier auf
eine Frachtschiff oder nach einer
anderen Version versteckt im Anhänger
eines milchlasters und warum tat er
sowas verrücktes ich meine er ist ja
nicht wirklich Klaus Kind oder
nun er hatte dazu einen guten Grund denn
in Georgien lag ein Haftbefehl gegen ihn
vor aber der abenteuerliche einreiseweg
weniger wurde ein paar Stunden nach
seinem Grenzübertritt verhaftet wegen
illegaler Einreise als auch wegen sechs
andere anhängiger Strafen
und natürlich fragt ihr euch nun zurecht
warum man freiwillig in ein Land reist
in dem man strafrechtlich verfolgt wird
nun es Rätsels Lösung ist das sakawili
bis heute in seiner Heimat niemanden
kalt lässt viele George unterstützen ihn
immer noch andere hassen ihn dagegen
sein Pech zu letzterem gehören auch
diejenigen die derzeit das Land regieren
ich werde von einem Regime gefangen
gehalten dass meine Gefangenschaft als
eine loyalitätsbezeugung zu Wladimir
Putin benutzt wie heißt der Willi
seitdem hat sich sein Gesundheitszustand
drastisch verschlechtert das liegt zum
Teil an den Hungerstreiks der inszeniert
hat aber es gibt auch Anzeichen für
deutlich besoffenes erregendere Umstände
in neuen Aufzeichnungen behauptete
ehemalige georgische Präsident und Putin
Gegner dass er vergiftet wurde es ist
ganz klar das Saka schwelige Gruppen
misshandelt und gefoltert wurde das sind
extrem scharfe Vorwürfe zu mal wenn
nicht vergessen dürfen das Saga Willi
seiner Zeit ein echter Darling der
US-Führung war und dass das Land
Regierungszeit in aller Eindeutigkeit
eine Mitgliedschaft in der EU und der
NATO anstrebt daher lobte er auch die
jüngsten Proteste gegen die aktuelle
Regierung
sie widerstanden Bravo ist der brutalen
Gewalt die gegen sie angewandt wurde
aber warum erzähle ich euch diese
Geschichte überhaupt nun weil sie ist
symptomatisch ist für etwas viel
Größeres etwas geopolitisches Georgien
baut nämlich zugleich wieder Brücken zum
Kremmen und die Frage ist warum denk mal
darüber nach wir sprechen von einem
kleinen Land von dem zwei Landesteile de
facto von Russland besetzt wurden
ähnlich wie es ab 2014 in der Ukraine
der Fall war Georgien und Russland
unterhalten deshalb sogar keine
diplomatischen Beziehungen mehr
zueinander auch der Flugverkehr zwischen
den zwei Ländern ist komplett
eingestellt gleichzeitig ist Georgien
ganz zurecht als gastfreundliches Land
bekannt im Laufe des letzten Jahres hat
es 10.000 Russen aufgenommen die vor
Putins Regime geflohen sind wie um alles
in der Welt ist es da möglich dass die
Führung offenbar um gute Beziehungen zur
Moskau holt welche Verbindungen gibt es
zwischen Moskau und der regierenden
Partei georgischer Traum und welche
Auswirkungen könnte der Krieg in der
Ukraine auf all dies haben heute werden
wir all diese Fragen natürlich
beantworten und zwar gleich nach einer
kurzen aber knackigen Werbebotschaft
unseres tollen Sponsors surfshark denn
surfshark hat nicht nur das heutige
Video möglich gemacht nein es hat auch
ein VPN ein Angebot das wirklich
empfehlenswert und vor allem sicher und
vertrauenswürdig ist so lockt es z.B
selbstverständlich keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit natürlich kann ein
Virtual Private Networks VPN einen nicht
vor allen Gefahren man muss nach wie vor
unsichthalten lassen und wissen was man
tut aber es stellt hier für ein Werkzeug
mit gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum
einen erschwert ist ein Kombination mit
anderen Vorkehrungen eure Aktion im
letzten nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören
mit Hilfe verschiedener
Sicherheitsfeatures könnt ihr so eure
Anonymität im Netz erhöhen z.B mit dem
integrierten klimberg das alle
unerwünschten Cookies und Papa Block
weiter Vorteil eines dass ihr so tun
könnt als wäre er an einem anderen Ort
so könnt ihr zum Beispiel auch Webseite
und Internetdienste zugreifen die dem
Land in mir gerade Seiten verfügbar
wären ob daheim oder im Urlaub damit
schlagt ihr Zensur und geoblocking ein
Schnäppchen Netflix und andere
Streamingdienste die ihre Inhalte nun in
den USA Anbieten von Europa ausnutzen
oder deutsches Internetfernsehen im
Ausland gucken mit surfshark kein
Problem und das ist noch lange nicht
alles denn mit nur einem Konto könnt ihr
wirklich alle eure Endgeräte im VPN
registrieren Handys Notebooks oder sogar
euren Smart TV so und wenn ihr den
Rabattcode politik.de angeht bekommt ihr
von unserer Schlag auch noch eine Rabatt
in Höhe von 83% und um deine ersten drei
Monate gratis dazu den Link zu diesem
Angebot findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter diesem Video also nicht viel los
besorgt euch surfen greift damit auch
gleichzeitig uns finanziell unter die
Arme das könnte übrigens auch direkt mit
Hilfe des Spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die Beschreibung gepackt
habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dankbar denn damit hättet
ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern so und
nun wieder schnell zur Beantwortung
unserer brennenden Fragen warum um alles
in der Welt wo die Georg ische Regierung
um die Gunst des großen erzfeins
Russland und das ausgerechnet nach
dessen Überfall auf die Ukraine nun
wieso oft finden wir die ersten
Antworten indem wir einen Blick auf die
Geschichte werfen also aufgepasst
[Musik]
die georgische Odyssee
bekanntlich waageorgien einst Teil der
so wird Union aber ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob alle von euch wissen dass
einer der wichtigsten wenn ich da der
wichtigste sowjetsführer von Deutschland
ja wir sprechen von keinem geringeren
als Josef Stalin der eigentlich Josef
sogar Willi hieß aber wir wollen mal
nicht voreilig sein denn bevor Georgien
Teil der UdSSR wurde gehörte es zu
anderen Imperium vom antiken
Griechenland über das römische Reich bis
hin zu bezahlt den Arabern und Persern
das heutige Orgien hat fast immer unter
der Kontrolle fremder Mächte gestanden
nur vom 10 bis 12 Jahrhundert war
Georgien selbst recht stark vereint und
wohlhabend aber danach begann wieder das
gleiche Lied Invasionen Plünderungen
Fremdherrschaft und Aufteilung in
mehrere Fürstentümer etwa um das Jahr
1800 warten die ersten georgischen
Fürsten darum sich Russland anschließen
zu dürfen und diese teile und herrsche
Strategie die damals schon von Moskau
betrieben wurde hatte schließlich Erfolg
etwa um das Jahr 1800 warten die ersten
georgischen Fürsten darum sich Russland
anschließen zu dürfen um Schutz zu
bekommen und natürlich bekamen sie ihnen
aber zu welchem Preis nun zu einem
ziemlich hohen denn jetzt hatten die
Russen mit ihrer Armee das Sagen
Georgien wurde zu einer randprovinz des
russischen Reiches dies führte auf der
anderen Seite den lokalen Nationalismus
was bei der Gelegenheit des
bolschewistischen Staatsstreichs in
Russland 1917 zur Ausrufung der
georgischen Unabhängigkeit führte aber
auch diese sollte nicht von langer Dauer
sein nur vier Jahre später im Jahr 1921
rückte die Rote Armee von drei Seiten
ein
[Musik]
das russenimperium nun unter dem Label
Sowjetunion raubte dem kleinen Volk
wieder seine Unabhängigkeit und
annektierte es kurzerhand danach begann
im neuen sowjetischen Georgien ein
gewisser Prozess der Industrialisierung
und Urbanisierung aber die Georgia
litten auch stark unter den typischen
Repressionen des sowjetsstaats und den
Kampagnen zu kulturellen und ethnischen
Homogenisierung dieser Prozess dauerte
bis 1991 als der Kollaps der UdSSR die
georgische Unabhängigkeit wieder
herstellte doch auch damit sollte nur
eine weitere Odysse beginnen sobald die
Unabhängigkeit erreicht war traten alle
möglichen Probleme auf ein blutiger
Bürgerkrieg vor allem in den auf
Selbstständigkeit dringenden
Teilrepubliken Akazien und südostizien
dazu eine schwere Wirtschaftskrise und
so weiter und so fort mitten in diesen
durcheinander wurde der letzte
Außenminister der Sowjetunion nach einem
Staatsstreichen 1992 vom Militär an die
Spitze des landesberufen und schwarze
brachte immerhin etwas Ordnung ins Chaos
bis Mitte der 90er Jahre waren die
Bürger Kriege zwar nicht gelöst aber
zumindest eingefroren die
Wirtschaftslage begann sich wieder
leicht zu erholen doch von 1991 bis 95
war das Bruttoinlandsprodukt und
dramatische 88% eingebrochen
[Musik]
kein Wunder dass sich die Probleme
häuften die Hälfte der Bevölkerung kam
nicht über die Runden Korruption
grassierte immer noch an allen Ecken und
Enden und Autoritarismus war zum
grundlegenden Regierungsstil geworden
aber 2003 kam es schließlich zu einem
Ereignis das Georgien fundamental
verändern sollte die Rede ist von der
sogenannten Rosenrevolution es war die
erste in einer ganzen Reihe von farbigen
Revolutionen den nächsten Jahren noch
Herrscher und Regimen aller Welt in die
brituier bringen sollten auslöser waren
Proteste gegen gefälschte Wahlen und wer
führte diese Revolution an genau unser
Freund sagt er Willi
[Musik]
von Beruf Jurist und ehemaliger
Justizminister unterscheward narze
rebellierte gegen seinen ehemaligen
politischen Partnern und forderte
schließlich dessen Rücktritt ein am Ende
musste Gerard Nase auf Druck aus den
eigenen Reihen und wegen der massiven
Straßenproteste das Handbuch werfen er
gab die Macht ab und 2004 im Jahr darauf
gewann Sarka Spiele die
präsentschaftswahl mit überwältigender
Mehrheit und dann passierte
ungeheuerliches das Land voll zog eine
Wende um 180 Grad durch knallharte
Maßnahmen zur Korruptionsbekämpfung
Sticker Orgien bis 2012 innerhalb
weniger Jahre im Jahresbericht von Franz
Paris international von Platz 133 auf
Platz 51 auf um 2 beeindruckende
Beispiele zu nennen man baute neue
Polizeireviere und zwar mit Glasfassaden
damit die Bürger jederzeit verfolgen
konnten was drin vor sich gehen und die
notorisch korrupte Verkehrspolizei wurde
von zackerspiele schlichtweg aufgelöst
er schickte alle Beamten nach Hause ein
paar Monate Hersteller hier auf den
Straßen aber stattdessen wurde eine neue
Polizei aufgebaut mit motivierten jungen
Leuten die ihre soliden Gehälter höher
schätzten als die Möglichkeit bei
Verkehrskontrollen die Hand aufzuhalten
parallel kurbelten echter Reformen die
Wirtschaft an das Land hatte sich eine
klare Ziel gesetzt eine Art liberaler
garteneden in Sachen Wirtschaft zu
werden dafür hat die regierungshaka
Spiele alles erwartbare getan und sogar
noch mehr sie führte flexible
arbeitsbestimmungen niedrige Zölle und
Steuern ein baute die Bürokratie ab und
öffnet sich der Außenwelt insbesondere
den Westen aber meine Lieben
visualpolitik Zuschauer es ist nicht
alles Gold was glänzt wohl Licht ist
fällt auch Schatten jede Medaille hat
zwei Seiten jeder Janos zwei Gesichter
jeder Klaus auch seinen Kinski und Saka
schwielies Regierungen zeigt nach einer
gewissen Zeit ebenso ein zweites Gesicht
schon bald gab es Vorwürfe über Angriffe
auf die Pressefreiheit Unterdrückung von
Oppositionsparteien und neue
Korruptionsfälle all das führte dazu
dass Saka Spiele 2007 zurück trat um nur
ein Jahr später 2008 die Wahlen erneut
gewinnen doch während seiner zweiten
Amtszeit wiederholten sich die Vorwürfe
obwohl die Wirtschaftsreform mit
fortgesetzt worden ja und dann kam es
noch schlimmer es kam zum Krieg mit
Russland
[Musik]
ihr erinnert euch an die beiden
separatistischen Teilgebiete ab Hasi und
südostizien von denen wir schon Sprachen
vor allem an der Demarkationslinie zu
südostizien kam es immer wieder zu
Scharmützeln zwischen den Separatisten
und georgischen Kräften sowohl
Zivilisten als auch Militärs die beiden
Parteien auseinanderhalten sollte
eigentlich eine kleine russische
Friedenstruppe die aber eigentlich auf
der Seiten der osteten Stand faktisch
waren beide Direktorin schon damals
russische Protektorate und ähnlich wie
später auf der Krim oder den Don Bass
baute Putin hier eine schlagkräftige
fünfte Kolonne auf um seine Nachbarstaat
zu destabilisieren es handelte sich
sozusagen um die Generalprobe für seine
Ukraine Strategie noch vier Jahre zuvor
2004 hatte saker spielen mit Charme
Druck und geschickter Diplomatie hat
scharrien eine dritte Separatisten
Republik innerhalb des kleinen
georgischen Staates unter die Tiefe
Verwaltung zurückgeholt nun hoffte er
das ihm ein solcher Handstreich auch mit
südostizien gelingen könnte doch damit
beginnt Hacker spiele einen
verhängnisvollen Fehler
am
8.8.2018 just an dem Tag an dem alle
Welt gebannt nach Peking sah weil dort
mit allem pumpty Olympischen
Sommerspiele eröffnet wurden rückte
Georgiens Armee in die Hauptstadt
südostiziens ein doch diesmal hat es
sogar Spiele die Rechnung ohne den
eigentlichen wird in der von gerade
einmal 50.000 Menschen bewohnten Gebirgs
Provinz gemacht der Krämer sah seine
Chance gekommen und zögerte nicht sie
wahrzunehmen Moskau Beschuldigte
sofortige Regierung eine ethnische
Säuberung durchführen zu wollen außerdem
waren bei dem Angriff auch russische
Soldaten ums Leben gekommen und es gab
noch etwas was eine Intervention
vermeintlich rechtfertigte wir haben auf
diesen Kanal schon öfter über die
karagern Aufdruck drin gesprochen sie
besagt das Russland der Beschützer aller
Russen oder russisch sprachigen sein
muss egal in welchem Ländern sie leben
die Bewohner Süd Ostsee sind zwar keine
ethnischen Russen aber etwa 90% des
Volkes der austreten liegt auf der
Nordseite des Kaukasus in Nordsee ziehen
und das ist eine kein Republik der
Russischen Föderation Osseten sind also
keine Russen ruskie aber sozusagen
russländer rassianie und in den Genuss
ein rassian zu werden im Rahmen des
ruski mehr der russischen Welt kann
natürlich jeder Mensch auf diesen ganzen
Planeten kommen dessen Land von Russland
kolonisiert und asimuliert wird na sind
das nicht herrliche Aussichten aber gut
mit den gleichen Vorwand den Russland
später noch zweimal benutzte um in die
Ukraine einzumarschieren wurde damals
also Georgien angegriffen der kriegsgang
Gerät für die Russen zwar zu einer
wahrlich tödlichen Slapstick und Murphys
so Orgie deswegen wirklich alle Schiefer
schief gehen konnte aber die winzige
georgische Armee hatte trotzdem keine
Chance putin war über das damalige
peinliche abschneiden seines Militärs
übrigens dermaßen geschockt dass er
höchstpersönlich eine dramatische Armee
Reform angeging zusammen mit seinem
Shooting Star Valerie Gerasdorf um
später fit für den Ukraine Feldzug zu
werden das sind das alles nicht geholfen
hat haben wir bereits in einem Video
lange vor Ausbruch der Koffein Invasion
beschrieben ich werde euch dieses Video
verlinken und wenn ihr es euch anseht
habe ich einen kleinen Tipp für euch die
Kommentare der Putin Fanboys unter
diesem Video sind pures Gold lasst sie
euch auf der Zunge zergehen denn ich
glaube nur wenige Dinge sind schlechter
gealtert als diese Ergüsse aber zurück
auf den Kaukasus die überlegenen
russischen Truppen vertrieben 2008 die
Orgie auf jeden Fall erstmal aus
südostizien und rückten dann weiter auf
georgisches Territorium vor bis auf 40
km kamen sie an die Hauptstadt des Herrn
während die Luftwaffe strategische Ziele
Angriff anders als in der Ukraine
dauerte dieser Krieg gott lob nur 5 Tage
unter Vermittlung von Frankreichs
Präsident sagt Musik kam es zu einem
Waffenstillstand doch Russland erkannte
in der Folge die Unabhängigkeit
abhasiens und südostizienz offiziell an
Willi hatte also seinen Wahlversprechen
die territoriale Integrität Georgiens
wieder herzustellen nicht gehalten und
schlimmer noch er konnte ein anderes
großes Problem des Landes auch nicht
lösen die niedrigen Löhne und niedrigen
Renten bei den Parlamentswahlen 2012
wurde seine Partei deshalb hat
abgestraft und verlor ihre Mehrheit ein
neuer politischer Akteur rückte ins
Rampenlicht der georgische Traum na
klingt das nach einer kitschigen
politmarketingnummer nun lasst uns doch
lieber mal etwas genauer unter die Lupe
nehmen ob es sich dabei um einen süßen
Traum handelt oder er einen Albtraum
der Klartraum eines Moskauer Oligarchen
seit 2012 dominiert die Partei
georgischer traumdigeorgische Politik
sie ist er Mitte links ausgerichtet
soweit nichts ungewöhnliches aber sie
wurde und wird beschuldigt Putins
Russland innerhalb Georgiens zu
beschönigen fest steht ohne die Tatkraft
ihres Gründers des Milliardärs Benzin
wäre die Partei nicht dorthin gekommen
wo sie heute steht es handelt sich also
weniger um eine echte Partei sondern mal
wieder um eine klassische politfirma
eines reichen Oligarchen und diese
Unternehmer ist zu seinem Vermögen
ausgerechnet wogekommen nun während der
wilden privatisierungsorgien in Russland
wenn wir also einen Blick auf die
Vorwürfe gegenüber wegen seiner
Verbindung zu Russland werfen wollen
müssen wir ihn erst einmal besser
kennenlernen also wir sprechen hier über
den reichsten Mann Georgiens ein wahrer
selfmade Milliardär das Kind eine Bitte
armen Arbeiter Familie die sich
angeblich nicht mal Schule leisten
konnte diese Herkunft machte ihn später
bei der georgischen Landbevölkerung
beliebt und behalte ihn zum Sieg bei den
georgischen Parlamentswahlen 201 12
gegen die Partei des aus einer tieflüsse
akademiker-familie stammenden sakash
Willi doch dem armen und Jungen Bettina
wurde Bildung nicht verwehrt zunächst
studierte er in Tiflis und machte seinen
Abschluss im Wirtschaftsingenieurwesen
dies reichte dem ambitionierten
emporkömling jedoch nicht 1982 ging er
nach Moskau um noch einen Doktortitel in
Wirtschaftswissenschaften draufzusatteln
in der sowjetmetropole lernte er im
Rahmen der Perestroika jedoch eher den
Duft des Geldes zu lieben denn der
Bücher er fängt an Computer und
tastentelefone zu importieren und zu
verkaufen es heißt ja nicht umsonst und
ist der Handel noch so klein so bringt
er mehr als Arbeit ein auf dem Kapital
dass er durch sein Geschäft verdient
hatte rote sich evernis Spiele jedoch
keine Sekunde aus als nach dem Zerfall
das so wird Union und dem Ende des
Kommunismus die privatisierungswellen
der sagenhaft riesigen Schätze Russland
so Schleuder Preisen losgehen weil er
ganz vorne mit am Start und schon damals
zeigte sich sein Talent als politischer
Stratege
[Musik]
denn er wusste ohne gute Beziehungen in
die Politik war bei der Privatisierung
des staatsvermögens kein Blumentopf zu
gewinnen 1990 gründete eine Bank und als
die Privatisierung losging verzichtete
über die bewusst auf das schnelle Geld
und die heftigen Auseinandersetzungen um
den lukrativenöl und Metallsektor
stattdessen kaufte er sich in eher
unpopuläre Eisenerzminen ein 1996 wurde
über eine Spiele Mitglieder der
bankhersteller einer Gruppe
einflussreiche russischer Bankier ist
die bei den russischen
Präsidentschaftswahlen war es jetzt in
unterstützten und hier zeigte bitte
welche gewiefter politischer
Schachspieler in ihm steckt statt
nämlich jetzt ihn direkt zu finanzieren
er lieber die Präsidentschaftskampagne
seines Konkurrenten Alexander lebt
dieser sprach im Gegensatz zu jetzigen
nämlich eher die Linke Wählerschaft an
auf diese Weise sollten dem Hauptgegner
ihr Ziels dem kommunistischen Kandidaten
genau stimmen entzogen werden der
kugelland lebt verwässertes sogar noch
Chancen und jetzigen wurde Präsident Eva
handelte für die Unterstützung Labels
später jedoch den Zorn seiner
georgischen Landsleute ein generell
lebend war nämlich eine der führenden
sowjetischen Militärs gewesen die 1998
für die blutige Niederschlagung von
unabhängigkeitsprozessen in tiefes
verantwortlich waren dabei wurden 21
Demonstranten durch die verwirrarmee
getötet und Hunderte verletzt und als
evalische Willi später nach Georgien
zurückgekehrt war und in die Politik
wollte musste er sich deswegen gegen
seine Kritiker verteidigen und das tat
er indem er seine Taktik von 1996 offen
liegt er gab zu dass alles eigentlich
nur dazu gedient hatte barisierten zur
Macht zu verhelfen schließlich hätte die
Rückkehr der Kommunisten wiederum auch
die Unabhängigkeit Georgiens gefährdet
denn diese forderten damals ja ganz
offen die Wiederherstellung der UdSSR
die Ironie an der ganzen Geschichte um
den Aufstieg der Kommunisten im Jahre
2000 zu verhindern wurde auch Wladimir
Putin auf den Präsidenten tot behilft
und zwar von der jetzigen klicke der
bankhersteller und mit Unterstützung des
bestens
[Musik]
die Rede ist vom gleichen Putin der
ebenfalls eine große russisches Reich in
den Grenzen der alten odssr wieder
herstellen will vom Regen in die Traufe
möchte man da sagen aber eins nach dem
anderen denn zunächst Kette 2003 unser
Held Eva nicht Willi in seine georgische
Heimat zurück um dort die
Rosenrevolution zu unterstützen damals
war also noch ein Freund sarkas Willis
und diese Unterstützung hielt bis 2011
an als er begann sein eigenes
politisches Projekt so starten die Rede
ist natürlich vom georgischen Traum der
Partei die bei den Parlamentswahlen 2012
eine Mehrheit gewonnen dadurch konnte
über mich Premierminister werden und
obwohl er kaum ein Jahr später plötzlich
beschlossen sein Amt aufzugeben blieb
aber nicht Willi in Wahrheit Herr und
Meister seiner Partei und heimlicher
Herrscher über das ganze Land nur wenige
in Georgien Zweifel daran dass evanes
Willi alles Fäden in der Hand hält auf
jeden Fall ist es eine Tatsache dass der
georgische Traum in letzter Zeit eine
ganz besondere Bedeutung erlangt hat und
warum nun überall seine Position
gegenüber Russland eine völlig andere
ist als die die der gute alte sarkash
willi1 vertreten hat eine Position die
übrigens auch nicht so recht mit den
sogar in der georgischen Verfassung
vorgegebenen Zielen einer Mitgliedschaft
in NATO und EU zusammenpasst auf jeden
Fall hat die Partei des georgischen
Milliardärs nach dem verbrecherischen
Einmarsch in der Ukraine eine höchst
sanfte Haltung gegenüber Russland
eingenommen aber die im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes Preisfrage lautet welchen
Grund hat die Partei des früher immer
für die georgische Unabhängigkeit
eintreten über nicht Willi ausgerechnet
jetzt auf Schmusekurs zu gehen mit einem
Diktator der seinen brutales Gesicht
immer mehr zeigt nun die Antwort lautet
mal wieder jetzt
ganz genau es ist die Angst davor dass
die Wirtschaft des Landes vollkommen
abstürzt wenn es sich mit Russland
anlegt denn wenn es um die Wirtschaft
geht mein Leben Zuschauer liefen die
letzten Jahre für Georgien nicht gerade
prickelnd und schließlich ist Russland
bei allen geopolitischen Differenzen ein
wichtiger Handelspartner für Georgien
schaut euch doch mal diese Tabelle an
wie ihr nur unschwer erkennen könnt ist
Russland der zweitgrößte
abnehmergeorgischer waren und
gleichzeitig der zweitgrößte Lieferant
des Landes und das erklärt vielleicht
warum dieser Regierung so oft
vorgeworfen wird Russlands Handlungen zu
beschönigen und ihre eigenen Beziehung
zu EU herunterzuspielen und es
überrascht auch nicht das Nachrichten
wie die folgende für das Image des
Landes im Westen nicht gerade förderlich
sind
georgischer Traum annulliert mit dem
Europäischen Rat das Abkommen vom 19
april 2021 in diesem Abkommen sollte
Georgien eigentlich bei der Entwicklung
seiner Demokratie unterstützt und enger
an die EU-Mitgliedschaft herangeführt
werden aber gut dieses
opportunistische hin und Herdes
georgischen Traums ist eigentlich nichts
wirklich neu ist schon 2019 war die
Aufregung groß als die Partei einen
russischen kommunistischen
abgeordney läuft zu einer Konferenz ins
Parlament einlud als gabrielloff sich
dann auch noch auf dem Stuhl des
Parlamentspräsidenten setzte und auf
Russisch eine Rede über eine
Partnerschaft Russlands und Georgiens
hielt explodierten die Georgien auf den
Straßen kam es darauf zu Protesten mit
Rücktrittsforderungen währenddessen
begann die Opposition auch eine
Wahlreform zu fordern damit die
Wahlergebnisse in Zukunft wirklich
proportional sind und was glaubt ihr was
dann passiert ist gegen alle Widerstände
haben die politischen Gegner den
Rücktritt des Parlamentspräsidenten und
die Wahlreform durchgesetzt wie also
auch die jüngsten Ereignisse wieder
zeigen in Georgien funktionieren
Proteste des Pudels Kern ist nämlich
dass ein großer vor allem der produktive
und urbane Teil der Bevölkerung
Georgiens eigentlich modern aufgeklärt
und er den besten gegenüber
aufgeschlossen ist der Wohlstand
Georgiens beruht darauf dass es sich um
ein wirtschaftsliberales Landhandel das
im isofling business-index der Weltbank
seit Jahren unter den ersten zehn
Staaten rangiert und zwar vor allen
EU-Staaten aus der Dänemark das alles
beruht jedoch vor allem noch auf sacker
Willis radikalen Reformen die für einen
Kahlschlag im Bürokratie und Korruptions
Dschungel sorgten deswegen liegt auch
heute noch Georgien im
korruptionswahrnehmungsindex von
Transparenz international reichen
EU-Staaten es hat also strukturell
wirklich Chancen in die EU aufgenommen
zu werden diese zivilisatorischen
Erfolge droht ivanischwillis Partei
jedoch zunehmend zu verspielen und am
überraschendsten dabei ist dass sie
trotz aller Demonstration und Skandale
weiterhin Wahlen gewinnt einer der
Gründe just als ihr Image richtig am
Boden lag brach Corona aus und
unglaublich aber war eine große Mehrheit
der Bevölkerung ist der Meinung dass das
pandemiemanagement in Georgien gut oder
gar sehr gut lief georgien ist also
tatsächlich eines der wenigen Ländern in
den kubit 19 die Regierung nicht
belastet hat sondern er im Gegenteil
einen Popularitätsschub gab und so
gewann sie 2021 erneut die
Kommunalwahlen auch wenn es wieder viele
Vorwürfe gab wegen Betrugs und
einschütterung in den Wahllokalen trotz
allem hat der russische Angriffskrieg in
der Ukraine einiges verändert und es ist
wahrlich spannend anzusehen wie kreativ
der georgische Traum nun mit dieser
neuen Herausforderung umgeht denn
womöglich könnte der Krieg entscheidend
für das Überleben der Partei sein und
auch entscheidend für die Zukunft
des Landes ihr fragt euch warum nun
schauen wir uns das doch mal etwas
genauer an aufgepasst
[Musik]
russische Migranten Segen oder Albtraum
auch wenn man nicht einer Meinung ist
mit Georgiens Regierung das verlod
universalenski höchstpersönlich die
Proteste in tiefes angestachelt hat man
kann durchaus sagen dass der Konflikt
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine auch
schon auf Georgien übergegriffen hat und
zwar weil dieses Land schon
hunderttausende Menschen aufgenommen hat
die vor den Folgen des Krieges geflohen
sind aber aufgepasst wir reden hier
nicht von ukrainischen Flüchtlingen
schaut euch mal das Jahr
vor putinskrieg fliegende Russen
verstärken alte Spannungen im nahen
Georgien Russen die vor der Einberufung
zum Krieg in der Ukraine nach Georgien
fliehen verstärken die schon seit
Generation bestehenden Spannungen
zwischen den beiden Ländern ganz genau
es geht um russische exzellanten die
entweder den Krieg und Putins Regine
kritisieren oder schlichtweg nicht das
Risiko eingehen wollten als
Kanonenfutter an der Front zu enden
deshalb sind weitaus mehr Russen als
Ukraine nachgeorgien gekommen von Beginn
des Krieges bis zu Putins Ankündigung
der massenhaft mobil machen im September
2020 waren schon etwas 40.000 nach
Georgien gekommen denn dieser und
dergleichen gibt es für sie nicht
russische Bürger können ohne Probleme
erst einmal ein Jahr im Land bleiben
aber dann kam es ganz dick gleich nach
Ankündigung der teilmobilisierung denken
plötzlich hunderttausende Russen in das
kleine Land der einzige Grenzübergang
hoch oben im Kaukasus war vollkommen
überlastet die Menschen meisterten den
beschwerlichen Weg zu Fuß die Rollkoffer
im Schlepp auf Fahrrädern oder sogar
elektroscootern man schätzt das etwa
100.000 von ihnen in Georgien geblieben
sind da sind fast 3% Bevölkerungszuwachs
in nur wenigen Wochen tief ist wurde
neben Riga und Berlin zu einem der
Sammelpunkte der neuen russischen die
astora Georgien erreicht damit zwar
nicht das Niveau von Ländern wie Estland
wo ukrainische Flüchtlinge bereits etwa
fünf Prozent der vorkriegsbevölkerung
ausmachten aber es geht dir dennoch um
eine sehr bedeutende Zahl der springende
Punkt ist jedoch dass dieser massive
Zustimmung aus Russland sowohl positive
als auch negative Effekte für Georgien
hat schaut euch dazu mal diese Tabelle
an
ein großer Teil der aus Russland
geflohenen sind hochqualifizierte
Fachkräfte vor allem aus dem IT- und
Technologie-Sektor und davon profitiert
jetzt auch Georgien tatsächlich haben
selbst die ersten und abgelegensten
kleinen Dörfer in Georgien einen
gewissen wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung
erlebt unser ist nur weil sie den Russen
Postadressen verkaufen damit sie dort
ihre firmensitzer registrieren können
die nach Georgien geflohenen Russen
haben schätzungen zufolge bereits rund
10.000 Unternehmen im Land gegründet
tatsächlich hatte der Kapitalzufluss
nach Georgien erhebliche Auswirkungen so
stiegen z.B die internationalen
währungsassagen des Landes im Jahr 2022
um 12,2% auf 4,9 Milliarden US-Dollar
und der Lari die Landeswährung bewertete
und 13% auf
wer jetzt aber denkt die Georgier würden
dies alles als puren Segen sehen er wird
gewaltig sie haben nicht vergessen was
Russland in 2008 angetan hat und die
Tatsache dass ein Fünftel des
Staatsgebiets noch immer unter russische
Herrschaft steht ist der
Völkerfreundschaft auch nicht gerade
dienlich viele Rosen die nach Georgien
gekommen sind erlebten Vorfälle von
Diskriminierung auch wenn sie beim
besten Willen nichts Böses gegen ihre
Gastgeber im Schilde führten und
natürlich geht eine Situation die den
sozialen Frieden bedroht auch zu Lasten
der Russen die Putin ablehnen denn wieso
oft Zahlen am Ende die anständigen
Migranten die Zeche der Sünde
ein Problem war dabei geradezu
unvermeidlich der zustrub der Russen
führte zu enormen Wohnraummangel die
russischen Flüchtlinge brauchen ja
schließlich ein Dach über dem Kopf und
das heizt die Nachfrage nach Immobilien
an verschärfen kann hinzu dass viele der
exzellenten digitale Nomaden also
Freiberufler mit teils home Einkommen
oder schlichtweg wohlhabende Leute sind
sie sind logischerweise fähig und bereit
mehr Geld für Wohnraum zu bezahlen als
die Einheimischen deswegen sind seit
Beginn des russischen ukrainischen
Krieges die Mietpreise in tief ist in
die Höhe geschossen Schätzungen von
Mietsteigerung von bis zu 210% aus die
Preise für Eigentumswohnungen sind im
Vergleich zu 2021 und 28% gestiegen doch
trotz des Drucks auf den georgischen
Immobilienmarkt kann man auch festhalten
dass Georgien von der Ankunft der
leistungsfähigen und zahlungskräftigen
russischen Exilanten profitiert
allerdings bleibt eine Schlüsselfrage
noch offen jetzt da Russland in der
Ukraine große militärische Verluste
erleidet und seine Kampfkraft
sichergestellt ist während es Georgien
offenbar immer besser geht könnte der
aktives es nicht wagen seine von
Russland vereinnahmten Staatsgebiete
zurückzufordern oder vielleicht sogar
zurück zu erobern
tja tut mir leid wenn ich euch da jetzt
enttäuschen muss höchstwahrscheinlich
wird dies nicht passieren und warum nun
es liegt nicht nur an der latent
russlandfreundlichen Haltung der
georgischen Regierung und der
herrschenden Partei zwar hat das
offizielle Titel ist die russische
Invasion der Ukraine Anfang 2022
verurteilt sich aber den internationalen
Sanktionen gegen Putins Regime nicht
angeschlossen von Waffenlieferungen an
die Ukraine kann da schon gar keine Rede
sein und auch wenn gegenwärtig die
Ukraine Russlands Militär macht gewaltig
zusetzen wir dürfen diese nicht
verharmlosen denn meine Lieben
visualpolitik Zuschauer verwechselt
nicht die Größe und Ausrüstung der
ukrainischen Armee die inzwischen zu den
15 größten der Welt gehört mit der
georgischen Armee die ist immer noch er
bescheidendimensioniert das liegt erst
einmal daran dass dieses Land nur 3,7
Millionen Einwohner hat weniger als
Russlands zweitgrößte Stadt Sankt
Petersburg vergessen wir auch nicht das
Georgien grenzt wo Putins gefolgt man
langsam kann er auf seine Privatarmee
unterhält und Georgien steht auch nicht
unter Schutzschirm der NATO es gebe
anders als bei der Ukraine nicht einmal
einen direkten Nachschubweg dorthin und
wir alle wissen ja mittlerweile aus
unzähligen visualpolitikvideos ohne
richtig gute Logistik ist kein Krieg so
gewinnen kurz um Georgiens Ausgangslage
ist viel schlechter als die anderer
kleiner explodierte Republiken wie
Estland Lettland oder Litauen die zur
NATO gehören und viel zu Verena handeln
können daher ist es eher wahrscheinlich
dass der georgische Traum die nach der
überstandenen Pandemie wieder
aufkommende Dynamik nicht stören will
und nebenbei versucht die Früchte des
russischen Exodus zu ernten und
schließlich wer weiß vielleicht
profitiert man ja sogar davon eine Art
Brücke nach Russland zu werden auch wenn
dafür schon ungemacht von anderer Seite
droht es ist notwendig sicherzustellen
dass Russland weiterhin die vollen
wirtschaftlichen Kosten der Sanktionen
zu spüren bekommt Georgien darf nicht zu
einem Korridor für die Umgebung der
wirtschaftlichen Beschränkungen werden
Nationaler Sicherheitsberater der
US-Regierung ich meine kann das kleine
Georgien sich wirklich leisten einer
jener Krisen Profiteure zu werden mit
denen der Krimi die westlichen
Sanktionen zu umgehen hofft naja die
weitaus mächtigere Türkei macht es ja
schließlich vor damit wäre allerdings
der echte georgische Traum und jetzt
meine ich nicht die Partei sondern den
von der schnellen Integration in den
Westen natürlich endgültig ausgeträumt
aber auch das hat Erdogan schließlich
Bravo Rös vorgemacht wie hoch ist noch
mal die Inflationsrate in der Türkei
schon wieder unter 60% vor kurzem lag
sie doch noch über 80 %. doch im Ernst
glaubt ihr diesen offiziellen Zahlen aus
Ankara wirklich na dann ist ja alles in
Iran aber das ist schon wieder ein Thema
für ein eigenes Video schließlich ist es
nach einem Jahr wieder höchste Zeit für
ein Erdogan Update bei uns damals haben
wir die heutige Entwicklung übrigens
auch vorher gesagt also Abo plus
Glöckchen nicht vergessen um die Zukunft
nicht zu verpassen in Georgien gehen die
Proteste auf jeden Fall weiter und die
Präsidentin des Landes Salome versucht
unterdessen die Wogen im Westen zu
glätten
Georgiens Präsidentin bereits nach einer
Woche der Proteste Europa und die USA um
die Beziehungen zu stärken die
georgische Präsidentin Salome Surah
beschwilli hat sich offen für eine
Annäherung an den besten ausgesprochen
und die Regierungspartner in tiefes
kritisiert aber ihre Befugnisse sind
begrenzt
[Musik]
ihr seht also für Konflikt und
Spannungen ist in diesem kleinen
kaukasusland auch in Zukunft gesorgt
georgien hat noch einen langen Weg vor
sich und deswegen werden natürlich auch
wir euch über das Land des politkinski
auf dem Laufenden halten aber nun ist
die Zeit gekommen an der ich euch gerne
um eure eigene Meinung bitten würde
meint ihr Georgien sollte sich den USA
unter Europäischen Union anschließen und
die Sanktion gegen Russland mittragen
oder kann es dem Land gelingen aus der
Kriegslage wirtschaftlichen Nutzen zu
ziehen welche langfristigen Folgen
könnte es für das Land haben sich die
Aufnahme in EU und NATO zu verschätzen
und was wird aus dem alten erzfein zaka
Spiele der schwer krank in Georgien im
Gefängnis machte hat er noch eine Chance
oder ist der inzwischen allen egal und
gebe es für die Hauptrolle in seinem
bio-pick nicht doch eine noch bessere
Besetzung als kindsky nämlich Nicolas
den catch
genau anders
[Musik]
wir sind auf eure Kommentare schon
mächtig gespannt also haut in die Tasten
und falls ihr dieses Video und unsere
Arbeit gut fandet teilt es mit euren
Freunden und lasst uns eine kleine
Spende über den Link in der Beschreibung
zu kommen wir danken euch von ganzem
Herzen macht's gut und bis zum nächsten
Mal
[Musik]